Kaya ano ba ang Qiskit?
Ang Qiskit ay isang open source software development kit
para sa pagtatrabaho sa mga quantum computer
sa antas ng mga circuit,
mga algorithm, at mga application module. Ang SDK na ito
ay nagbibigay-daan sa sinuman na mag-program sa mga tunay na quantum computer mula sa
kanilang laptop. Sa dalawang linya ng code, maaari kang mag-access
ng iba't ibang quantum system, mula sa superconducting
hanggang trapped-ion na mga qubit. Gusto mo bang tularan ang gawi ng isang quantum computer?
Palitan lang ang isang linya ng code
at i-simulate ang iyong mga quantum circuit sa aming high-performance
simulator. Ang Qiskit ay ginagamit ng dose-milya ng
libo-libong tao sa buong mundo na nagsisikap na
buuin ang kinabukasan. Ikaw man ay isang researcher, developer,
o nagsisimula pa lang,
ang Qiskit ay may
mga feature na angkop sa iyong pangangailangan,
na nagbibigay-daan sa sinuman na gumawa ng mga bagay
tulad ng pagbuo ng iyong unang quantum circuit,
pagpapatakbo ng cross-domain na quantum algorithm,
at pag-aaral ng mga pangunahing quantum phenomenon.
Marahil ngayon na ang tamang oras para sumali ka rin
at mahanap ang lahat ng tools na kailangan mo,
kasama na ang mga tunay na quantum machine
at ang SDK sa pamamagitan ng Qiskit,
at isang komunidad na handang tanggapin ka
at sagutin ang anumang tanong na maaaring lumabas sa daan.
Maaari kang magsimula ngayon
sa Qiskit.